this is what he's been waiting for the
whole time yeah why why are you so
excited about this
[Music]
it's fun
Adventure
are you nervous no I'm good this is the
highest I forget what the the
history is great it's like the highest
bridge in the world it doesn't work
anymore it's obviously out of
construction but uh that's a beautiful
day we got lucky it rains over 200 days
a year in here and we got a beautiful
sunny day that we get to spend on that
railroad this is great I love it
good morning Evan today is day six I
think is it yeah we arrived at Sky Quay
I could see my own breaths
okay so what's good about the Skagway
Alaska Evan we are gonna go on uh crazy
train ride really old train that's on
really narrow tracks I could hear it
already
you think so I heard it I heard that
let me show you the idea let me show you
the agenda this is what they give us
they give us a daily agenda and on the
cover of Skagway for today is this train
and we're gonna go on it and I'm gonna
go outside on the train while it's
bending around and Breakneck speeds so
if you don't hear from us again well I
guess you don't see this video
we're gonna be okay we're gonna have fun
let's go before we head out we need to
have some breakfast
[Music]
everyone wants to come outside of the
train yeah because he likes Adventures
let's go to the edge
this is what he's been waiting for the
whole time yeah why why are you so
excited about this
but
Adventure
look beautiful
are you nervous no I'm good this is the
highest I forget what the the
history that's great it's like the
highest bridge in the world it doesn't
work anymore it's obviously out of
construction but uh that's a beautiful
day we got lucky it rains over 200 days
a year in here and we got a beautiful
sunny day so that we get to spend on
that railroad it's great I love it
thank you
[Music]
train this then it's done it got warm
good to stretch the legs a little bit
yeah and I pass out on the train I had a
nap I took another picture of her
sleeping it was great okay we're gonna
walk around downtown yeah and uh go eat
some find some famous Mexican food
apparently here it's insane and then a
coffee shop and then the halibut fish
and chips before heading back to the
boat it's a really small downtown so not
that much to see but we're gonna make
the most of it as per always
this is downtown that's it it's one
strip
it's the famous
Mexico place
it's just a bus
[Music]
you like it
it's hot
just came out from the kitchen
good good you found this
are you on fire
uh it is actually very hot right now and
my mouth is uh
yeah a little spicy not too crazy yeah
like stop glacial Coffee House
lattes and smoothies and they asked Nina
what does she want a latte or smoothie
she said one of each
and then with everyone she doesn't like
um
here we go octane smoothie yeah
Evan do you want to explain what
happened
the coffee shop oh it was closed on
Sundays they didn't update their Google
Maps so that's fine but now we're gonna
go to Lucy's Bakery and get some
legendary cinnamon rolls and maybe
something else
so I guess we should came earlier eh
it's interesting so they are they're all
out of the cinnamon rolls uh
it's interesting you know it's like
the first place is closed
and they don't hire somebody to they've
got all these cruise ships right this
place they don't make enough food
another place is closed until two but
then the boats leave
pretty quickly afterwards it's like the
entrepreneurial spirit is not uh quite
alive here
but uh it's okay moving on we'll find
something else we always do
[Music]
we are here Alaska cane legs
king crab legs and fresh halibutes fish
and chips
[Music]
okay Nina's going in for her oysters and
bisque look at this view by the way
while she puts on her dressings there
huh look at that first oyster fresh
Alaska oyster
[Music]
creamy she's liking it thumbs up
good okay I haven't tried this soup
Lobster
[Music]
oh yeah creamy creamy and lobster very
lobstery good combination
lunch was good yeah
gonna go back to the boat walk him off a
bit yeah back to the boat
we head out
and then see what kind of fun we do on
the boat
[Music]
okay it is what time is it six o'clock
oh eight o'clock eight o'clock yeah it's
dinner time dinner time what did you do
before dinner workout you worked out
yeah you had a good workout pretty good
yeah pretty good I thought it was really
weak okay yeah well I go to the gym and
I'm doing my work family pick up the
weights I look at the weights
yeah and then I realized that I'm like
okay
yeah I mean then I realized I was they
were in kilos and I'm used to pounds
which is a 2.2 conversion so yeah they
didn't feel so bad
and it worked out I just chill in a
cabin
all right we're going to a dinner this
did uh this restaurant is hard to book
Nina got us in let's go yeah I did I did
let's go
[Music]
actually
good
[Music]
it's
um
you feeling good Evan
four
[Music]
they had a band did you catch any of the
band no oh they had a band playing yeah
they had some good songs yeah Evan was
singing along Nina was too no I didn't
know fever you sing into fever fever
okay where do you want to go we gotta
walk on the food yeah
good
[Music]
hello hello we are in Sitka Alaska we're
gonna be not swimming with sea otters
we're going to see sea otters we're
gonna do some amazing things
it is hot in Alaska Nina well I'm sure
takes some amazing fantastic b-roll
while you're laughing
I'm ready to go I am ready for a great
day let's go
[Music]
get bacon crispy bacon you're happy
bacon yeah you like it happy bacon am I
a happy Baker yeah do I want to be a
happy bacon yeah okay I'm a happy bacon
what do you do uh caught up on a little
work uh right about Sitka found an
awesome coffee shop for us to go to okay
uh the way the locals go yeah not the
tourist traps not the tourist traps
where the locals go now we're getting
off the boat we have to take tenders
yeah we have about
an hour or so in the city yeah and then
we're gonna go on our sea otter a
wildlife Quest
[Music]
ing come to you and me
us yeah
[Music]
it's supposed to be raining all the time
here but we've had nothing but gorgeous
weather which is very good luck just
great things come to us with all of the
hitting the ceilings
we're bringing great things to us let's
go
into the coffee but you have to go
through this bookstore
oh quirky
you say don't talk to me this is the
coffee place
[Music]
[Applause]
oh wow is that good yeah
everyone wants to take to the fair
enough Castle
but it's very sketchy from this alleyway
you know those stores say come come come
come inside let's walk inside to show
you something like that was good yeah
wow because it's like nothing under just
like an Alleyway going now it's a
beautiful staircase super safe and not
unsketchy
[Music]
tomorrow we eat broccoli today is for
ice cream
foreign
snack
before we hit on our head on our
Excursion
you know when you're in Alaska you have
to eat some seafood
okay Nina's diving in on the king crab
rolls
good nice thumbs up from Nina this is a
thumbs up for life
[Music]
time for this discussion and you kept
talking about it yeah we have 10 more
minutes I'm excited you excited look at
how cute you look as always yeah have I
seen Otto before yeah uh yeah you're
probably at a zoo I don't think we've
ever seen him in the wild yeah so let's
go see some sea otters we have to take
the boat club yeah the boat to go out to
see the Seattle sea otters and other
other wildlife
and we'll see how good Nina's camera
skills are to capture these little tiny
creatures from far away what do you
think maybe one will come up and give
Nina kiss
no it could happen
[Music]
back to the boat Nina was feeling a
little sick yeah I usually get crazy
sick she's sick and then just decided
you know what whatever I'm not gonna get
sick this is fun and then I had fun no
it was it was very wavy yeah it was very
bumpy
okay where are we going we're gonna go
to the cafe
okay maybe get a little snack yeah
and then we do actually let me go last
time we do a little bit of work over
there ketchup get some water get some
salt in US
[Music]
okay let's go
[Applause]
[Music]
we need to eat I don't want to eat too
late yeah that's true what did you do
earlier what did I do earlier yeah your
work did I yeah you did some work what
did I do I don't know I helped you yeah
did you helped me work okay that's what
I did yeah Nina's learning and getting
better and in so many ways and so many
things so we did some of that today we
love Nina okay now to go to eat
so we were all ready to go to in in the
Chini uh yeah in the Chinese restaurants
that Asian restaurant as we walked by
and this restaurant that we're trying to
get our list on and came up to me say
hey we have a cancellation you guys want
to join somewhere here
[Music]
[Applause]
what's cool is there yeah yeah yeah I
love it oh did you get that one yeah
it's cool I haven't give it a try
it's good that's beef the tacky beef the
turkey
raw meat raw beef
okay it's good
[Music]
cute that's so good
try it
wagyu beef
delicious
good that's crazy
get some of that wagonina
[Music]
try your cheesecake Evan we have a
really good Japanese cheesecake in
Toronto
so we'll see how it compares to that
Uncle tetsu is called
very light
I forgot what this is
the brownie or something
this is very light that's very rich
but they're both pretty good
so we just came back to our cabin yeah
it's a nice dinner it's amazing yeah
tonight's dinner is actually really good
yeah even Evan's like even Evan's a food
snob
[Music]
he's been to so many cruises by far this
is the most
that's a low bar though Cruise food
usually not great no but this this food
yeah no this is really good he said he
had a best lobster in his life yeah
wasn't it yeah it was right not you yeah
no the no the lobster is really good
yeah the fish is very good too very
moist not like the fish and chip that we
had on the dock okay but this is
actually good yeah people are very
friendly they came over and talked to us
say hi very chatty like that yeah no
they're very funny yeah yeah so we're
just gonna chill yeah relax and then get
ready for tomorrow yep
well yeah what it's yes yep
good morning Kevin hi Michael good
morning I'm naked you're not naked
hold on hold on
good morning let's go
So today we're gonna be at Ketchikan
this is our last fourth stop and
tomorrow's gonna be a sea but you know
what today we're gonna go eat some crap